good morning everyone flights on today
six hours 54 minutes and we wish you a
safe and pleasant flight
hijack is about a plane that leaves from
Dubai to London Plains being hijacked
and it's not clear why
operation has commenced I play Sam
Nelson Sam is an ordinary man in an
extraordinary situation he's a very
successful business negotiator and he's
driven to get back home I just want to
get home to my family
I wanted to shoot this show as close to
being in a real hijack situation as
possible
we brought in the real plane it had to
feel like you were really there with the
passengers and that you were really
experiencing that moment
until you know these people are do
nothing we had the shell of a real
cockpit connected to run off of flight
simulator all of the computer displays
in the flight deck are as realistic as
possible the integration of the volume
screen is one of The Cutting Edge
aspects of our industry at the moment it
helps create a level of authenticity for
the audience the lights move past the
windows at the same speed and angle as
the sun really passes the windows of a
plane flying from Dubai we've paid
attention to every Last Detail there's a
ticking clock to tell a real-time
Thriller over seven hours of the plane
heading towards London each episode is
the play-by-play of what happens on the
plane we are second by second minute by
minute hour by hour edge of your seat so
don't make them do this there's more and
more tension a twist and turns it's a
hell of a roller coaster ride intense
adrenaline you are a passenger in that
plane sit down in your seat and buckle
up your seatbelt
thank you